this latest project in the buck we're
doing a kickstarter yes for it and i
understand it's about and i'm quoting it
sex love fertility and how the
expectations of gender roles have shaped
modern relationships
do tell that's interesting in the book
um
i
have been
thinking about wanting to do a story
about fertility for a long time and to
get extremely you know personal
the whole genesis for the story the
woman in the story
gabby when she was young she had an
ectopic pregnancy which is a
potentially fatal type of miscarriage
when i was in my early 20s a girl i was
dating
had this ectopic miscarriage she had to
be put into surgery and that this
happened a long time like 10 years ago
and
that got my wheel spinning of
these fertility issues that women go
through because after that happened with
her
she was told that the odds of her
getting pregnant again were very slim
and if she were to elect to have
children she would probably have to go
through some type of fertility treatment
so that happened 10 years ago that was a
seed that was planted in my mind
then i do all these then i have uh then
i do my indie films and do all this
stuff then i'm thinking okay i want to
the seed blossoms into a story of a
woman trying to get pregnant of a and
living in the midwest and why
can't she get pregnant and how does this
affect
their relate her relationship with her
husband
and
what if she's got substance abuse issues
um you know and it just
and it took years and years of of
being in my mind
and then a script sort of blossomed
you